In today's Cloud Minute I'll show you how to create a postgres instance via Cloud Launcher.
Starting on the Cloud Launcher homepage click database
and then click PostgreSQL
Click launch on Google Cloud Platform
Pick the project where you'd like
the Postgres instance to be created and then click the continue button
It may take a couple minutes for the next screen to appear.
You will see a progress bar indicating that it is initializing.
Give the VM a name and configure it in a way that makes sense for your project.
Again launching the instance may take a couple minutes.
Note the username and password.
Click SSH to login to the machine using the in browser terminal.
Now your postgres instance is created.
Please check out our other cloud minutes.